This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个IHeart播客。保证真实。您是否有意愿去做出真正的改变？LaCite学院为您提供依赖与心理健康课程。获取必要的技能，
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the difficulties of health and and dependance. Construise a career enrichisance
以陪伴和支持那些面临健康和依赖困难的人们。构建一份充实的职业生涯，
to service of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
服务于全国的法语社区。在法语中追求卓越，这是可能的，
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. . Souttened by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes.
与LaCite学院一起。访问Collage LaC。由加拿大卫生部支持。那些眼睛里空洞无物。
They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Creveit and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum.
它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。邪恶，醒醒。我是那个亲眼目睹Creveit和DePippo谋杀案的人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后，表现得毫无悔意，似乎并未受到影响。
I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential, and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby.
我说我没有罪。我会把这个秘密带进坟墓。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听Bone Valley频道中的《魔鬼的采石场》。快乐是必不可少的，也是难以捉摸的，但现在有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开启您通往更快乐生活的旅程，那就是《快乐101》。这是一个由我，Hoda Kotby主持的新播客。
If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Cotfi is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born.
如果您渴望获得灵感来最大化您的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的直播聊天。打开您免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《快乐101》并立即收听。由CVS呈现的《快乐101》与Hoda Kotby。每个人都视我为一名足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共处。
This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuinely. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier-N-E-R-Nand-es, and listen to Learning to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts or whatever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture,
这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是Javier "Chicharito" Hernandez，请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Champs》播客中，我们正在与文化界最热门的人物交谈，
like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like so much more to do. Like Prince, he dropped like 30 albums. We dropped like five right now. That's the rate we got to be going.
比如Sway Lee。你意识到你有多传奇了吗？我很感激。我本想说，但我感觉，伙计，我还有更多的事情要做。就像Prince，他发行了大约30张专辑。我们现在只发行了五张。这就是我们必须前进的速度。
Yeah, that's a good attitude. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is, as always, so great to have you here back. for another episode and back for a very big, big episode for us today.
是的，那是一个很好的态度。无论处于什么时代，《Drink Champs》都会为您带来最大牌的人物和最直白的对话。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《Drink Champs》。大家好。我是Jemma Spon，欢迎回到《你的20岁心理学》，这是一个我们讨论20岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。一如既往，很高兴你能回来参加另一集，今天对我们来说是一个非常非常大的剧集。
Today we are talking about a major, pretty huge discussion happening in society at the moment, whether that's online, whether it's in the medical community, amongst concerned parent groups, friend groups, policy makers, and that is the idea that everybody has a diagnosis these days. I'm sure you have heard it. Everybody has ADHD. everybody's anxious, everybody's on the spectrum, everybody could be depressed, everybody could have OCD, BPD, PTSD, etc. Is this true? Is it true? Does everybody, or could everybody actually have a diagnosis in this day and age? Or is that just public opinion? Is that just public opinion
今天我们正在讨论目前社会中发生的一个重大且相当巨大的讨论，无论是在网上，还是在医疗界，在关注的家长群体、朋友圈、政策制定者之间，那就是现在每个人都有诊断结果的观点。我相信你一定听说过。每个人都有多动症（ADHD），每个人都很焦虑，每个人都在谱系上，每个人都可能抑郁，每个人都可能有强迫症（OCD）、边缘性人格障碍（BPD）、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）等等。这是真的吗？是真的吗？在这个时代，每个人都有，或者每个人都可能有一个诊断结果吗？还是那只是公众舆论？那只是公众舆论
making a problem C, or not even a problem, making a change seem bigger than it is? Is it just increased visibility and reduced stigma that is giving the impression that more people have diagnoses than before. And if numbers are actually increasing, should it be cause for concern? You know, should we be worried about how other people see themselves or are seen by the medical community? I have to say a lot of my friends naturally work in the mental health space. And this is something that we cannot shut up about because it is so, so much more nuanced than what you may read or see online. It's so much more nuance than what fearmongering would have you believe. So I thought it was time to do this episode, do a whole episode on this topic and like crack
让一个问题看起来很严重，或者甚至不是问题，让一个变化看起来比实际更大吗？仅仅是可见度的增加和污名的减少，才让人觉得比以前有更多的人被诊断出来吗？如果数字确实在增加，这应该引起关注吗？你知道，我们是否应该担心其他人如何看待自己，或者被医疗界如何看待？我必须说，我的很多朋友自然是在心理健康领域工作的。这是我们无法停止讨论的事情，因为它比你在网上阅读或看到的内容要微妙得多。它比危言耸听者让你相信的要微妙得多。所以我认为现在是时候做这一集了，做一个关于这个话题的完整剧集，并像撬开
open the lid on this discussion. I want to thank our researcher Libby as well for her incredible deep dive and diligence with this episode. Before we even get started, we also get to talk about one of her papers that she published last year in this episode, which is so exciting. that we have somebody working for us who is literally doing the research on this at the same time. So we've got a lot in store. Sorry, another disclaimer. It also goes without saying this episode is going to be simply a space for discussion and research and reflection. It is not for passing judgment.
这个讨论的盖子一样。我也要感谢我们的研究员Libby，感谢她对这一集的深入研究和勤奋工作。在我们开始之前，我们还要谈谈她在去年发表的论文之一，这太令人兴奋了。我们有一位为我们工作的人，她同时也在做这方面的研究。所以我们有很多内容。抱歉，还有一个免责声明。不用说，这一集将仅仅是一个讨论、研究和反思的空间。它不是为了评判。
It is not for ending a conversation. It is for starting a conversation. Not everything in this episode will apply to everyone. It may not apply to you. and you also, you know, you don't have to agree with what we say or everything that we say in this episode if it doesn't actually match your lived experience or what you've been seeing. You know, we've done a ton of research to ensure our take on this is balanced. But of course, there are nuances that we just like simply can't capture in an hour. So feel free to DM us with your own
它不是为了结束对话。它是为了开启对话。这一集中的一切并不适用于每个人。它可能不适用于你。而且你，你知道，如果你听到的内容与你的生活经历或你所看到的并不相符，你不必同意我们所说的或我们在这集里所说的一切。你知道，我们做了大量的研究来确保我们对这个问题的看法是平衡的。但当然，有些细微差别是我们无法在一个小时内捕捉到的。所以请随时通过私信告诉我们你自己的
takes, with your stories, with your experiences. If you feel like something is missing, you can also leave a comment if you're listening on Spotify as well if, I don't know if there's something else you want us to include in this episode, but I just wanted to put it out there that this is obviously an ongoing discussion that society is having and this is just our small contribution to the conversation. So without further ado, let's get into the episode. To begin with, before we can even start to dive into this very widespread idea that everybody has a diagnosis these days, we firstly have to actually fact-check that. Like, is that true? Like, our start point here has to be whether the data and rates of certain conditions are actually increasing. Because if
看法、你的故事、你的经历。如果你觉得缺少了什么，如果你是在Spotify上收听，你也可以留下评论，如果，我不知道还有什么你想让我们在这一集中包含的内容，但我只是想说明，这显然是社会正在进行的持续讨论，而这只是我们对对话的一点小贡献。所以事不宜迟，让我们进入这一集。首先，在我们开始深入探讨这个目前非常普遍的观点，即现在每个人都有诊断结果之前，我们首先必须对它进行事实核查。比如，这是真的吗？比如，我们的起点必须是某些疾病的数据和发病率是否真的在增加。因为如果
they're not, like, this conversation is kind of nullified, you know, we have to actually be able to distinguish between actual numerical shifts and shifts in public opinion. This is what the research says. The research says that rates of certain conditions, specifically all forms of departments, specifically all forms of depression, all forms of anxiety, have experienced a very, very sharp increase in the last few decades with a major increase, like, during three years after COVID. Those numbers, they are very easy to see. It is very easy to look at any, literally any data on this and see that things are tracking up per capita per 100,000. What you may not know, though, is that for other conditions, specifically to do with neurodivergence, the way we actually measure rates can be really confusing.
它们没有增加，那么这个对话在某种程度上就被否定了，你知道，我们必须能够区分实际的数字变化和公众舆论的变化。研究是这样说的。研究表明，某些疾病的发病率，特别是所有形式的抑郁症，所有形式的焦虑症，在过去几十年里经历了非常非常剧烈的增长，在新冠疫情后的三年里有大幅增加。这些数字，它们很容易看到。查看任何，字面上任何关于此的数据，并看到人均每10万人的发病率都在上升，这非常容易。然而，你可能不知道的是，对于其他疾病，特别是与神经多样性有关的疾病，我们实际测量发病率的方式可能会非常令人困惑。
So we don't actually and can't actually always have an accurate number, if that makes sense. Like it really depends entirely on which condition you want to talk about and then what kind of rate we're talking about. So whether we mean true prevalence, lifetime prevalence, recorded diagnosis, self-diagnosis, medication use, or like wider public conversation. because these things do not rise and fall in exactly the same way as we would typically expect, right? So, for example, prevalence rates could be reducing, but medication use could be increasing. So that gives us two different stories. Lifetime prevalence could be increasing, but diagnosis rates at the current moment could be staying the same or reducing. ADHD is probably like the clearest example of why it is actually hard to pinpoint, like, how many people are experiencing,
所以我们实际上并没有，也不能总是得到一个准确的数字，如果这说得通的话。这完全取决于你想谈论哪种疾病，然后我们谈论的是哪种发病率。所以无论我们是指真实患病率、终身患病率、记录在案的诊断、自我诊断、药物使用，还是更广泛的公众讨论。因为这些事情并不会像我们通常预期的那样完全同步地上升和下降，对吧？所以，例如，患病率可能在下降，但药物使用可能在增加。所以这给了我们两个不同的故事。终身患病率可能在增加，但目前的诊断率可能保持不变或在减少。多动症（ADHD）可能是为什么它实际上很难查明，比如，有多少人正在经历，
this are diagnosis rates going up. I will say, like, numerically, they have risen. There has been a huge increase in adult diagnoses between 2000 and 2018 in UK data, US data, Australian data, prescribing has also risen in several countries. I think in the UK, there's been a 51% increase in patients being prescribed medication over the last five years. But that is not the only part of this picture. A 2025 systematic review looking at post-2020 ADHD prevalence actually found no actual conclusive evidence of a real rise in underlying prevalence. So what that means is that even though diagnosis assessment demand prescribing has clearly increased, Essentially, when these researchers looked at 40 plus studies, they concluded that actually underlying
诊断率是否在上升，最清楚的例子。我会说，从数字上看，它们确实上升了。在英国数据、美国数据、澳大利亚数据中，2000年至2018年间成人诊断数量有巨大增长，处方量在几个国家也有所上升。我认为在英国，过去五年中被开具药物的患者增加了51%。但这并不是这幅图景的全部。一份2025年的系统性综述查看了2020年后的ADHD患病率，实际上没有发现任何关于潜在患病率真正上升的确凿证据。所以这意味着，即使诊断评估需求和处方量明显增加，本质上，当这些研究人员查看了40多项研究时，他们得出的结论是，实际上潜在的
that prevalence probably hasn't changed. It's just that people are showing up for services. It's just that they are using the correct language for what they've always been experiencing. It's just that they are getting help. They're also getting later stage diagnoses. These individuals probably should have been diagnosed a lot. earlier, it's only now that they are counting, but the underlying prevalence has always probably been the same. Autism tells a very similar story. Actual diagnosis rates have risen over time.
患病率可能并没有改变。只是人们开始寻求服务了。只是他们正在使用正确的语言来描述他们一直以来的经历。只是他们正在获得帮助。他们也正在获得更晚期的诊断。这些人可能应该早得多被诊断出来，只是现在他们才被统计进去，但潜在的患病率可能一直都是一样的。自闭症的情况也非常相似。实际诊断率随着时间的推移而上升。
There's been an eightfold increase in the UK over the last 20 years. But again, much of the literature suggests this is not because of some sudden biological epidemic. You know, some people would want you to believe that, that it's vaccines, that it's pesticides, whatever. It's not that. it's rising recognition. It's improved identification amongst population groups that used to be missed, especially girls and especially people of colour. That is also combined with a reduced stigma, which is meaning that people feel more accepted to have this part of them be given a label. We really need to examine this because historically, diagnostic stereotypes have been really, really narrow. For a very long time, many diagnoses were simply shaped around a very limited
在过去20年里，英国的诊断率增加了八倍。但同样，大部分文献表明，这并不是因为某种突发的生物学流行病。你知道，有些人会让你相信这一点，说是疫苗，说是杀虫剂，等等。不是那样的。这是认知度的提高。这是在过去被遗漏的人群中，特别是女孩和有色人种中，识别能力的提高。这也与污名的减少相结合，这意味着人们觉得被贴上这个标签更被接受。我们真的需要审视这一点，因为从历史上看，诊断的刻板印象一直非常非常狭窄。在很长一段时间里，许多诊断仅仅是围绕一个非常有限的
template of what the typical person with the condition looked like. And often that template was based on the people who were most visible, most disruptive, most easy to identify, or most represented in research. That usually meant we based our entire idea of what a mental health condition or what neurodivergence looked like based on just the population group that happened to be studied first. I cannot overstate how narrow the clinical definition used to be because of that. Because for the first 30 to 40 years of ADHD research, for example, 98% of the people who were being studied were boys under the age of 18. And so the definition or the understanding we have or have had in the past has been formed on that. Most of the first tests on medications that were used
模板形成的，即典型的患病者看起来是什么样的。而且那个模板通常是基于那些最显眼、最具有破坏性、最容易识别或在研究中代表性最强的人。这通常意味着我们基于仅仅是第一批被研究的人群，形成了我们对心理健康状况或神经多样性是什么样子的全部概念。我怎么强调都不为过，临床定义过去因为那个原因有多狭窄。因为例如，在ADHD研究的前30到40年里，98%被研究的人是18岁以下的男孩。因此，我们过去拥有或曾经拥有的定义或理解就是基于此形成的。大多数用于ADHD的药物的首次测试，
for ADHD, medications that are still used now, that the basis of those medications are still active in medications we take now for ADHD. Those original tests were exclusively done on boys and men. And so for years, the dominant image has been of the hyperactive little boy who couldn't sit still, who interrupted constantly, who ran around, who was obviously, who was obviously. obviously very much struggling in ways that inconvenienced other people, and which were probably very, very confusing for him and everybody involved. The issue is that this image, it's not incorrect. It's just not entirely correct.
那些现在仍在使用的药物，那些药物的基础在今天我们服用的ADHD药物中仍然有效。那些最初的测试完全是在男孩和男人身上进行的。所以多年来，主导形象一直是那个坐不住、不断打断别人、跑来跑去、显然在以困扰他人的方式挣扎，并且对他本人和所有相关人员来说可能都非常非常困惑的多动小男孩。问题是，这个形象，它不是不正确。它只是不完全正确。
It's just not reliable. It's just one image of one kind of person. And that makes it harder to recognize people whose difficulties look quieter, whose difficulties looked more internal or more socially acceptable, especially if they had been fundamentally conditioned because of their race or because of their gender to behave differently. You know, the example a lot of people give now is like a girl who daydreams and forgets and procrastinates and is sensitive and feels overwhelmed and has these,
它只是不可靠。它只是某一种人的一个形象。这使得人们更难识别那些困难看起来更安静、困难看起来更内在或更社会可接受的人，特别是如果他们因为种族或性别而受到根本性的条件反射，表现得不同。你知道，很多人现在给出的例子就像一个做白日梦、健忘、拖延、敏感、感到不知所措并且拥有这些，
has a really elaborate imagination, probably previously wouldn't have been diagnosed with ADHD. but perhaps that's what she was what she was going through. Or, you know, a child of color in like a primarily white community may have been corrected more from an early age, you know, by their parents who were trying to keep them safe, keep them safe from standing out or by teachers or members of the community who made excuses for the white kids, but not for them, meaning that their behavior was curtailed, became less obvious, they masked more and they didn't get the
拥有非常丰富的想象力的女孩，可能以前不会被诊断为ADHD。但也许这就是她正在经历的事情。或者，你知道，一个主要在白人社区中的有色人种孩子，可能从很小的时候起就被他们的父母纠正得更多，你知道，因为他们的父母试图保护他们，保护他们不引人注目，或者被老师或社区成员纠正，他们为白人孩子找借口，但不对他们找借口，这意味着他们的行为受到限制，变得不那么明显，他们掩饰得更多，他们没有得到
diagnosis or weren't seen as having a condition or having a label that they probably did have all along. So basically, as our understanding expands, we are seeing this reflected in changing numbers, right? As our understanding of masking, as our understanding of conditioning expands, essentially it means that we are realizing some delays in our recognition
诊断，或者没有被视为患有某种疾病或拥有一个他们可能一直都有的标签。所以基本上，随着我们的理解扩展，我们正在看到这反映在不断变化的数字中，对吧？随着我们对掩饰的理解，随着我们对条件反射的理解扩展，本质上这意味着我们意识到我们在识别方面存在一些延迟
of how different conditions show up in different people. You know, from the outside, it might look like suddenly there is this epidemic. It is genuinely just a form of social catch-up. And essentially we are just bringing people into the fold and giving people the resources and the understanding that they probably always should have had. Right.
关于不同疾病如何在不同人身上表现出来。你知道，从外面看，这可能看起来好像突然出现了这种流行病。这确实只是一种社会追赶的形式。本质上，我们只是把人们纳入其中，并给予人们他们可能一直应该拥有的资源和理解。对。
And a big contributor to those increase in diagnostic rates that we are seeing is actually a lot of people who are in their 20s and who were in their 30s, some of them even in their 40s, who are looking retrospectively at their lives or who are finally kind of recognizing something about themselves and getting help. So it means that the level has been well below where it probably should have been for many, many years and then the last, let's say, five, ten years,
而我们看到的诊断率增加的一个重要贡献者实际上是很多20多岁、30多岁，甚至有些人40多岁的人，他们正在回顾自己的生活，或者终于在某种程度上认识到关于自己的一些事情并寻求帮助。所以这意味着这个水平在很多很多年里一直远低于它可能应该达到的水平，然后是过去，比如说，五年、十年，
it's actually matched all at once where it should have been for 40 years or longer. I would argue OCD is probably going to go through this in the near future. You know, our idea of OCD right now is kind of similar to what our idea of autism or ADHD was like maybe 20 years ago, at least our public knowledge of OCD is still very narrow. A lot of people still imagine OCD as being about cleaning, checking locks, being orderly, lacking things neat, but many people with OCD experience really intrusive taboo thoughts. they experience mental rituals, reassurance seeking, repeated checking that happens internally
它实际上一下子就达到了它应该在40年或更长时间里达到的水平。我认为强迫症（OCD）在不久的将来可能会经历这个过程。你知道，我们现在对强迫症的想法有点类似于我们20年前对自闭症或ADHD的想法，至少我们对强迫症的公众认知仍然非常狭窄。很多人仍然认为强迫症是关于清洁、检查锁、有条理、把东西整理得整整齐齐，但许多强迫症患者经历的是非常侵入性的禁忌想法。他们经历心理仪式、寻求保证、反复检查，这些发生在内部
as much as it does externally. And that's not how people often see it. Some people spend years not recognizing their experiences as OCD because it doesn't match the cliche, the way that a young girl's experience with ADHD didn't match the cliche back in the day. I know I've spoken about my experience with OCD. in the past, but I literally didn't know I had OCD until I was 23 or like 24. And I literally, I studied psychology. Like, I worked in mental health research. And I didn't realize this. And the
和外部一样多。而人们通常不是这样看待它的。有些人花了很多年时间没有意识到他们的经历是强迫症，因为它不符合陈词滥调，就像一个年轻女孩的ADHD经历在过去不符合陈词滥调一样。我知道我过去谈论过我的强迫症经历。但我直到23岁或24岁才知道我有强迫症。而且我真的，我学习心理学。就像，我在心理健康研究领域工作。但我没有意识到这一点。而
reason why was because the description and the way people talked about it was so narrow. Psychologists before this, like gave me so many labels for what I was going through. And none of them felt accurate and nowadays it's like so insane to me that it wasn't picked up like I used to I think I've talked about this in an episode before but I used to have to pray in the exact same way every single night I did that for like 18 years of my life as a child I literally used to have to stare at the sun constantly to reassure myself it wasn't going to explode like I genuinely think I've done permanent damage to my eyes because of that like that's OCD that was for me a sign of OCD And that's just like some examples.
原因是因为描述和人们谈论它的方式太狭窄了。在此之前的心理学家，给了我很多关于我正在经历的事情的标签。没有一个感觉是准确的，如今对我来说，它没有被发现简直太疯狂了，就像我以前，我想我在之前的一集里谈过这个，但我以前每天晚上都必须以完全相同的方式祈祷，我作为孩子做了大约18年。我真的曾经不得不一直盯着太阳看，以向自己保证它不会爆炸，我真的认为我因为那个对我的眼睛造成了永久性的伤害，就像那是强迫症，那对我来说是强迫症的一个迹象。而这只是像一些例子。
So behind every increase in numbers we are seeing in society that for some people may point to an epidemic, for some people may indicate that people are putting it on. These, like the stories that like mine are what it's behind this. It's just individuals who are finally understanding themselves. One final point on this, there was something this other paper I read spoke about that reflects why rates are increasing all of a sudden. and that's because the way that stigma has been slowly reduced over the past few decades. Not completely, but it's definitely been reduced. And that's meant that a diagnosis is no longer scary. This has allowed people to accept something about themselves or their child, for example,
所以，我们在社会中看到的每一个数字增长背后，对于某些人来说可能指向流行病，对于某些人来说可能表明人们在装病。这些，就像我的故事一样，是这背后的原因。这只是那些终于了解自己的人。关于这一点最后一点，我读到的另一篇论文中提到了一些东西，反映了为什么发病率会突然增加。那是因为污名在过去几十年里是如何缓慢减少的。不是完全减少，但它绝对减少了。这意味着诊断不再可怕。这使得人们能够接受关于自己或他们的孩子的一些事情，例如，
that they may have always known. This paper in particular discussed how parents, that used to be historical examples of parents who actually would avoid getting a formal diagnosis for their child, even though medical advice was very clear that this child had ADHD or had autism because they were, you know, concerned about how a label might negatively impact their kids or, like, they had misinformation about how diagnoses were recorded in medical records and they thought that that label might get out as they tried to apply for uni or work or went on to do other things. And so they felt like it was the right decision to not get their
他们可能一直都知道。这篇论文特别讨论了父母，过去有历史例子，父母实际上会避免为他们的孩子获得正式诊断，即使医疗建议非常明确，这个孩子患有ADHD或自闭症，因为他们，你知道，担心标签可能会对他们的孩子产生负面影响，或者，他们对诊断如何在医疗记录中记录有错误信息，他们认为那个标签可能会在他们申请大学或工作或继续做其他事情时泄露出去。所以他们觉得不让他们的
child diagnosed and not perhaps put a barrier in their way that that was previously like definitely was a barrier, right? Back then the stigma was so intense that, and still is in many ways, but back then especially, they thought that they were doing the right thing. They thought that they were protecting their child from being seen as different. Slowly, over many, many, years, you know, we have come to realize that somebody is not doomed because they have ADHD or if they have autism or if they have depression or anxiety or any number of things. Like they live beautiful full lives. Like they can do so much that everything that everybody else can. And so although stigma is like not completely eliminated, has been reduced or replaced as visibility has improved,
孩子被诊断，不给他们设置障碍，这在以前确实是一个障碍，是正确的决定，对吧？那时污名太强烈了，而且在很多方面仍然如此，但那时特别强烈，他们认为他们是在做正确的事。他们认为他们是在保护他们的孩子不被视为与众不同。慢慢地，经过很多很多年，你知道，我们已经意识到，某人不会因为患有ADHD或自闭症或抑郁症或焦虑症或任何数量的事情而注定失败。就像他们过着美丽充实的生活。就像他们可以做所有其他人能做的事情。所以虽然污名并没有完全消除，但随着可见度的提高，它已经减少或被取代，
as services have improved, as acceptance for people's differences has improved as well. And what that means is again, as people see themselves represented, as people see that getting a diagnosis is not all doom and gloom, naturally increasing prevalence is going to follow that through recognition. And I think that is a really amazing thing. So that's the first explanation. The rise in diagnoses that everybody is seeing and worried about is really just this. It's not that these people were previously fine. And now they're not. It's not that they're faking it. It's just that these people have perhaps never been okay. They've previously been missed. They previously were not counted in the recorded rates. Now they are. And yes, that seemingly is happening all at once, but when you look at
随着服务的改善，随着对人们差异的接受度的提高。这意味着，同样，随着人们看到自己被代表，随着人们看到获得诊断并不是世界末日，随着认知度的提高，患病率自然会随之增加。我认为这是一件非常了不起的事情。所以这是第一个解释。每个人都看到并担心的诊断率上升实际上就是这样。并不是说这些人以前很好。现在他们不好了。并不是说他们在装病。只是这些人可能从来没有好过。他们以前被遗漏了。他们以前没有被计入记录的发病率中。现在他们被计入了。是的，这看起来好像是一下子发生的，但当你观察
that over the period of time that it should have happened. So for example, if you take everybody who is being diagnosed at 12, 15, 27, 47, and you imagine they all got diagnosed at the same age, you would see that actually rates are not increasing as much as you think. Yes, there's been slight bumps, but actually still prevalence rates, when you view them in that way, are remaining pretty consistent with only slight variations. Okay, when we return, I want to talk about another way that diagnoses or rates of diagnosis for certain conditions are seemingly increasing because of how the DSM is changing, because of how we categorize certain conditions is changing. We're also going to talk about the role of big farmer and corporations.
它在应该发生的时间段内。所以例如，如果你把所有在12岁、15岁、27岁、47岁被诊断的人都算上，并且你想象他们都在同一个年龄被诊断，你会发现实际上发病率并没有你想象的那么高。是的，有一些轻微的波动，但实际上，当你以那种方式看待它们时，患病率仍然保持相当一致，只有轻微的变化。好的，当我们回来时，我想谈谈诊断或某些疾病的诊断率似乎正在增加的另一种方式，因为《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）是如何变化的，因为我们对某些疾病的分类方式正在改变。我们还将谈谈大药企和公司的角色。
Stay with us. You and a pal in Montreal and Oceaga, with four nights at residents in downtown Montreal, flights from Porter Airlines, two weekend gold tickets, and $1,000 cash. Please love me. Lord, Zara Larson. Ray, somber, 21 pilots, and more. Download I-Hart Radio. Listen to I-Hard new music for 10 minutes and enter to win. Osiaga, 2026. Every day you listen is another chance to win. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was
和我们在一起。你和一位朋友在蒙特利尔和Oceaga，在蒙特利尔市中心居住四晚，乘坐Porter航空公司的航班，两张周末金票，以及1000美元现金。请爱我。Lord, Zara Larson. Ray, somber, 21 pilots, 等等。下载I-Hart Radio。收听I-Hard新音乐10分钟并参加赢取。Osiaga, 2026。你收听的每一天都是赢取的机会。在那一刻，感觉好像永远持续下去。我以为我活不下来了。我
terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fair to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so.
很害怕。那些眼睛里空洞无物。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一个谋杀案吗？是的，先生。可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，先生。强奸和谋杀一个孩子。这是最糟糕的情况。我想是这样。
People, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app. Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts.
人们，醒醒。我是那个亲眼目睹Crevette和DePippo谋杀案的人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后，表现得毫无悔意，似乎并未受到影响。我说我没有罪。我会把这个秘密带进坟墓。在IHeart Radio应用程序上收听《魔鬼的采石场》。播客或您获取播客的任何地方。
And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaVa for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression.
要收听无广告且包含独家内容的《魔鬼的采石场》，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅LaVa for Good Plus。嘿，我是Hoda Kotby，播客《快乐101》与Hoda Kotby的主持人。在一起，我们将与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话，比如当女演员Olivia Munn分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。我经历过乳腺癌，然后帮助我的母亲度过乳腺癌，那更困难。有很多了解产后抑郁症的人。
I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions. ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from?
我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听《快乐101》与Hoda Kotby。因为他们的新星是Javier T. Torito Hernandez。每个人都视我为一名足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共处。我仍然有很多问题。我们从哪里来？
What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barza? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary.
死后会发生什么？你如何处理取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？从日常平凡到深刻非凡。
This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life
这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深入交谈，脆弱的一面会显露出来。阴谋论会被摆上桌面，目标和教训会被分享。所有这一切在生命中
has an order perfect and all is just. Wait me. I'm here to connect. We are here to connect
都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等待我。我在这里连接。我们在这里连接
The Chicharito. Oh Javier and Chacharito Randez and together with IHard Radio. We're going to make the ordinary
Chicharito。哦，Javier和Chacharito Randez，与IHard Radio一起。我们将让平凡
extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts
变得非凡。保持密切关注。这是一个carac。哇。在IHard Radio、Apple Podcasts上收听《学习做人》
or wherever you get your podcast. Mainstream media is full of crude depictions of the unhoused stories that shame and blame. and paint the unhoused as a monolith. We The Un-House is the podcast that's changing that.
或您获取播客的任何地方。主流媒体充满了对无家可归者的粗俗描述，这些故事羞辱和指责，并将无家可归者描绘成一个单一的群体。《我们，无家可归者》是改变这一点的播客。
I'm Theo Henderson, creator, and host. And for years, I've created a space where the un-housed and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed Un-Housed parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. Weidian Houses a two-time Webby and Signal Award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Gio Wichler, a street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge impact online and in her community.
我是Theo Henderson，创作者和主持人。多年来，我创造了一个空间，让无家可归者和他们的倡导者可以讲述他们自己的故事。仅在过去几个月里，我就采访了无家可归的父母、移民、互助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQTIA+社区，以及制定影响无家可归者生存法律的政策制定者。《我们，无家可归者》是一个两次获得Webby和Signal奖的节目，未来还有许多令人兴奋的嘉宾。本周请收听我对Gio Wichler医生的采访，她是一位街头医生转型的网红，她与无家可归者社区的工作在网上和她的社区产生了巨大的影响。
Listen to Weythian House on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. To understand why everybody has a diagnosis or it feels that way these days, We also need to understand that diagnostic systems are not written in stone. They are revised classifications. They are shaped by evidence, cultural debates, cultural norms, clinical needs, and often politics, which I don't think I see a lot of people talking about, but politics and cultural context changes how we see certain conditions. For example, PTSD, that only became a diagnosable condition in the 1980s,
在IHard Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方，收听《我们，无家可归者》。要理解为什么每个人都有诊断结果，或者这些天感觉是这样，我们还需要理解诊断系统不是刻在石头上的。它们是修订后的分类。它们是由证据、文化辩论、文化规范、临床需求以及通常的政治所塑造的，我认为我没有看到很多人在谈论这一点，但政治和文化背景改变了我们看待某些疾病的方式。例如，创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），它直到20世纪80年代才成为一种可诊断的疾病，
after the Vietnam War because all these veterans came home and were lobbying for this condition to be included. The removal of like homosexuality as a mental condition only happened in 1973, right? Our clinical guidelines for, and I hate to say this, but like for what is an impairment or not an impairment mentally is constantly being revised to actually match what is accurate. Like PTSD should always have been in the DSM. Homosexuality should be. never have been in the DSM, right? And so we are naturally going to see changes in this document as our understanding of people and our understanding of human psychology changes. So the DSM is the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders. I should have said that originally,
在越南战争之后，因为所有这些退伍军人回家并游说将这种疾病包括在内。将同性恋作为一种精神疾病的移除只发生在1973年，对吧？我们的临床指南，我讨厌这么说，但对于什么是精神上的损害或不是损害，一直在修订以真正匹配什么是准确的。比如PTSD应该一直都在DSM中。同性恋应该从来不应该在DSM中，对吧？所以随着我们对人和人类心理的理解改变，我们自然会看到这份文件中的变化。所以DSM是《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》。我本来应该在最初就说出来的，
but it's used for every single diagnosis worldwide by every single mental health professional. And the reason we are seeing increases is also because of how the criteria for certain conditions has changed in the DSM. So the first edition of the DSM was published in 1952. It included 106 diagnoses. In 1980, the DSM 3 came out. I think that jumped to 264 diagnoses. For the DSM-5, this was published in 2013. It went up to 300. There are now over 300 conditions listed in the DSM if we count subtypes, if we count specific conditions. And this last edition also revised things like clinical thresholds, specifies symptom clusters, and provided more examples that would affect who could actually qualify for a diagnosis.
但它被全世界每一位心理健康专业人士用于每一个诊断。我们看到增加的原因也是因为DSM中某些疾病的标准是如何改变的。所以DSM的第一版出版于1952年。它包括106个诊断。1980年，DSM 3出来了。我想那跳到了264个诊断。对于DSM-5，这是在2013年出版的。它上升到了300。如果我们计算亚型，如果我们计算特定疾病，DSM中现在列出了超过300种疾病。而这最后一个版本还修订了临床阈值、指定症状群，并提供了更多例子，这将影响谁实际上有资格获得诊断。
So I think this is something that maybe some people don't understand about getting diagnosed. It's not like you go into a psychologist office or a psychiatrist office and they let you talk about yourself for a couple of hours and then go, oh, I definitely know this is what's going on with you. Like there are real clinical guidelines and there are hoops people have to jump through in order to receive a label that would then give them access to medication, help, services, adjustments. I think that's something that people with who are worried about rising rates. And again, it's not that you shouldn't be worried, but who are worried about rising rates don't understand, which is that you can get a diagnosis the way that you could get a script for an antibiotic.
所以我认为这是有些人可能不了解关于获得诊断的事情。这不像你走进心理学家办公室或精神科医生办公室，他们让你谈论自己几个小时，然后说，哦，我肯定知道这就是你身上发生的事情。就像有真正的临床指南，人们必须跳过障碍才能获得一个标签，然后给他们提供药物、帮助、服务、调整。我认为这是那些担心发病率上升的人，而且同样，并不是说你不应该担心，但那些担心发病率上升的人不了解的事情，那就是你可以像获得抗生素处方一样获得诊断。
Like, that is not the case. ADHD is a really useful example of how these changes have changed how we see ADHD, basically, or how we diagnose it. In 2013, the DSM5 raised the age by which symptoms should be present for a diagnosis to occur from 7 to 12. And that is more in line with what clinicians were seeing. That naturally meant that suddenly a lot more people, qualified. They also lowered the symptom threshold, the amount of like basically symptoms that
就像，事实并非如此。ADHD是一个非常有用的例子，说明这些变化如何改变了我们看待ADHD的方式，基本上，或者我们如何诊断它。2013年，DSM-5将诊断所需的症状出现年龄从7岁提高到12岁。这更符合临床医生所看到的。这自然意味着突然有更多的人，有了资格。他们还降低了症状阈值，基本上就是症状的数量
needed to be present, especially for older adolescents and adults, they lowered it from six to five. So suddenly people who had five and not six were now included as well. And the reason they did that was because they were like, it just seems kind of arbitrary that you could have over half of the symptoms and still not be diagnosed, but having one more than over half would give you a diagnosis. those changes made it easier for adults, especially people whose symptoms were never recognized in childhood to meet diagnostic criteria later on that previously would have excluded them, despite what they were dealing with. Now, that doesn't necessarily mean that they became more lenient. You might think that. You might say, well, look at this, it's become easier.
需要存在，特别是对于年龄较大的青少年和成人，他们将其从6个降低到5个。所以突然间，那些有5个而不是6个的人现在也被包括在内了。他们这样做的原因是，他们觉得，你可能有一半以上的症状却仍然没有被诊断，但多一个超过一半就会给你一个诊断，这似乎有点武断。这些变化使得成年人，特别是那些症状在童年时期从未被识别的人，更容易在以后符合诊断标准，这些标准以前会排除他们，尽管他们正在处理这些问题。现在，这并不一定意味着他们变得更宽容了。你可能会那样想。你可能会说，好吧，看看这个，它变得更容易了。
No, no, no. Like there were many, many clinical trials, many, many clinical trials, many, many many discussions that was, like, this change was debated for years before it took place. And it just better matches what experts and clinicians now believe has been true about ADHD all along. PTSD is another interesting case, aside from what we've already mentioned, because its most recent classification shows that diagnostic broadening does occur, but diagnostic narrowing can also happen all it once. So the DSM-5 actually revised PTSD pretty substantially. It moved PTSD into an entirely new chapter of the manual. Previously, it was an anxiety disorder. They now know that's probably not the case. It's definitely not the case. It's a trauma and stressor-related disorder. It also changed the
不，不，不。就像有许多许多临床试验，许多许多临床试验，许多许多许多讨论，这个变化在发生之前被辩论了多年。它只是更好地匹配了专家和临床医生现在认为关于ADHD一直都是真实的情况。PTSD是另一个有趣的案例，除了我们已经提到的之外，因为其最近的分类显示诊断范围确实在扩大，但诊断缩小也可以同时发生。所以DSM-5实际上相当大幅度地修订了PTSD。它将PTSD移到了手册的一个全新章节中。以前，它是一种焦虑症。他们现在知道那可能不是真的。它绝对不是真的。它是一种创伤和压力相关障碍。它还改变了
symptom clusters. It removed the old requirement that a person needed to respond with intense fear, healthlessness or horror initially, and it narrowed the criteria around the kinds of trauma somebody had to be exposed to to get a diagnosis of a PTSD. So basically, it made it more difficult. Some aspects broadened, some narrowed. And it's not, again, it's not that criteria keep expanding, and that's the only changes that are happening. It's just that our understanding is changing for conditions that previously were perhaps gate kept by medical standards that weren't accurate, we're just giving it a more realistic, a more realistic kind of bar that needs to be jumped over. And then for others, we're kind of saying, perhaps like our understanding
症状群。它删除了旧的要求，即一个人最初需要以强烈的恐惧、无助或恐惧来回应，并且它缩小了关于一个人必须暴露于何种创伤才能获得PTSD诊断的标准。所以基本上，它使它变得更困难了。有些方面扩大了，有些缩小了。而且它不是，同样，它不是标准一直在扩展，而且那是唯一正在发生的变化。只是我们的理解正在改变，对于以前可能被不准确的医疗标准把关的疾病，我们只是给它一个更现实的、更现实的需要跳过的门槛。然后对于其他人，我们有点在说，也许像我们的理解
that was, was incorrect in the opposite way. I really need to stress, this is not like, because of public pressure. Not at all. This is not because of public pressure. This is not because the cultural conversation changed. It's because the scientific conversation changed first. The people who make these changes to the DSM are not just doing it because somebody online is making an argument that, you know, everybody has ADHD these days. They're not just doing it because of outside pressure.
那是不对的，而且是完全相反的错误。我真的需要强调，这并不是因为公众压力。完全不是。这并非因为公众压力，也不是因为文化对话发生了改变。这是因为科学对话首先发生了改变。那些对《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）做出这些修改的人，并不是因为网上有人争论说“现在每个人都有多动症（ADHD）”才这么做的。他们不是仅仅因为外部压力才做出这些改变。
They are debating this routinely. They are trialing this deliberately and across many different populations. to be more truthful to the human experience. I want to quickly return to something I mentioned before, and that is the example I gave of that change to the ADHD criteria, from six lowered to five, and how many symptoms need to be present, and the difficult decision of deciding on a threshold.
他们经常对此进行辩论。他们是在许多不同人群中审慎地进行试验，以更真实地反映人类的体验。我想快速回到我之前提到的一个例子，即我给出的关于ADHD诊断标准修改的例子，从六项症状降低到五项，以及关于需要多少症状才算达标的艰难决策。
Here is something we still don't have a consensus on. When it comes to a diagnosis, who is impacted enough to receive said diagnosis? How long does symptoms have to be present before a diagnosis is given? What is personality? What is small quirks and what is a problem? You know, this is the debate that happens online a lot, which is that all of us at times can be a little bit idle-minded, all of us at times can have low mood,
这是我们尚未达成共识的问题。谈到诊断时，谁受到的影响足够大以至于需要接受诊断？症状需要持续多久才能给出诊断？什么是人格？什么是小怪癖，什么是问题？你知道，这是网上经常发生的争论，即我们所有人有时都会有点心不在焉，我们所有人有时都会情绪低落，
or are people who want things organized or coherent. What is personality? what is environment, what is just quirky behaviour, and when does it get serious enough for a label? I think this is what is really worrying some people. Have we over-pathologised things so much to the point that everybody can see themselves represented in a diagnosis? Perhaps the same way that everybody can see themselves represented in tarot cards or astrology or personality tests. I would say no, I would say the level of impairment you have to experience to get a formal diagnosis is still pretty significant. But self-diagnosis is, I think, where people get
或者有些人希望事情井井有条或连贯一致。什么是人格？什么是环境？什么是单纯的古怪行为？什么时候它严重到需要贴上标签？我认为这正是让一些人感到担忧的地方。我们是否过度病理化了事物，以至于每个人都能在诊断中看到自己的影子？也许就像每个人都能在塔罗牌、占星术或人格测试中看到自己一样。我会说不，我会说要获得正式诊断所必须经历的损害程度仍然相当显著。但我认为，自我诊断是人们对此感到担忧的地方。
concerned about this. There's a concept called concept creep that was created by an Australian academic that basically talks about how, in the last couple of decades, our language for things that, like specific language for things has expanded and slowly creeped out of the bounds of what it meant such that it applies to more and more people. And that, Expansion in many ways is morally progressive because it lets us recognize the harms that used to be minimized or invalidated by gatekeeping something. But it also has caused us to pathologize ordinary distress and essentially believe in the existence of a problem or a disorder, even if maybe there isn't one because of how overly relatable our language has gotten, because of how
有一个由澳大利亚学者提出的概念叫“概念蔓延”（concept creep），它基本上讨论了在过去几十年里，我们对事物的语言——即对事物的特定描述——是如何扩展的，并慢慢超出了其原本的含义，以至于适用于越来越多的人。这种扩展在许多方面是道德上的进步，因为它让我们能够认识到那些曾经因设置门槛而被最小化或否定的伤害。但它也导致我们将普通的痛苦病理化，并从本质上相信某种问题或障碍的存在，即使可能根本不存在，因为我们的语言变得过于容易引起共鸣，因为
essentially easier it is for people to see themselves represented in something because it looks less serious from the outside. Let me give you an example. I saw this video the other day on TikTok from this young woman. She couldn't have been more than 17 and she was talking about the signs that you may have BPD. And some of the signs were like, you love really deeply. You get mad when people reject you. You are very sensitive. Let me ask you a quick question. Who of us cannot relate to that? Genuinely, who doesn't get up? upset when people reject them. Who doesn't feel good about being in love? Yes, on a very intense scale, this is BPD. It may represent people with BPD and can cause impairment. But it can also,
从本质上讲，人们更容易在某件事中看到自己的影子，因为它从外部看起来没那么严重。让我举个例子。前几天我在TikTok上看到一个年轻女子的视频。她顶多17岁，她在谈论你可能患有边缘性人格障碍（BPD）的迹象。其中一些迹象是：你爱得很深；当别人拒绝你时你会生气；你非常敏感。让我问你一个简单的问题。我们中有谁不能感同身受呢？真心地问，谁在被拒绝时不会难过？谁在恋爱时不会感觉良好？是的，在非常强烈的程度上，这确实是BPD。它可能代表了BPD患者，并可能导致功能受损。但它也可能，
this representation can represent pretty much everybody. And I'm sure we can all think of a few examples of this where the information we are specifically seeing online is simply too general and doesn't actually represent what the terms, what the words, what the clinical guidelines actually are. Here's the other thing about psychology and mental health content like that. It does really well. It gets really great engagement because people are filming them in a way that is generalized. That's exactly why they do it this way. They want it to be relatable.
这种表述几乎可以代表所有人。我相信我们都能想到几个例子，我们在网上看到的特定信息实在太笼统了，并没有真正代表这些术语、这些词汇或临床指南的实际含义。关于心理学和心理健康内容，还有一点是：它们非常受欢迎。它们获得了非常好的互动，因为人们拍摄它们的方式是泛化的。这正是他们这样做的原因。他们希望它能引起共鸣。
This content wants people to see themselves and resonate with what they're saying. and send to their friends and save it and forward it and whatever. But then people end up believing something deeply and very serious about themselves. That may not be accurate. May. At times it is. But even if it is accurate, if you're only going off of this content, it's going to be based on a very simplified version of things that may actually not be
这些内容希望人们看到自己并与他们所说的话产生共鸣，然后发送给朋友、保存、转发等等。但随后人们最终会对自己产生某种深刻且非常严重的认知，这可能并不准确。可能。有时是准确的。但即使是准确的，如果你只根据这些内容，它将基于一个非常简化的版本，这实际上可能根本没有
helpful anyways. Another reason this content does really well is because as people, we are constantly looking for something that will help us make sense of our experiences. Basically, when we're young, especially, you know, this girl in this video is like 17. Her target audience is probably other teenagers. When we're in our teens, 20s, 30s, and life in general is very confusing. Someone giving you a general label to grasp onto that explains your experiences, especially in this way, is very reassuring.
任何帮助。这些内容之所以非常受欢迎的另一个原因是，作为人类，我们一直在寻找能帮助我们理解自身经历的东西。基本上，当我们年轻时，特别是，你知道，视频里的这个女孩才17岁。她的目标受众可能是其他青少年。当我们处于十几岁、二十几岁、三十几岁时，生活总体上是非常令人困惑的。有人给你一个可以抓住的通用标签来解释你的经历，尤其是以这种方式，是非常令人安心的。
The issue is that that can actually become. a self-fulfilling prophecy as you mold yourself to fit the label, not the other way around. And when you don't have clinical help alongside it, I have some friends who are psychologists, psychiatrists, social workers, and more and more, they're talking about how people will come into appointments or sessions, essentially with two to three labels. They'll be like, I have BPD, I have bipolar, I have OCD, I have ADHD. And it's only after a little bit of investigating, or in fact like some confusion that like this person doesn't actually seem to match the criteria that they will ask the client and the client will be like oh I diagnose myself online
问题在于，这实际上可能成为一种自我实现的预言，因为你塑造自己去适应这个标签，而不是反过来。当你没有临床帮助时，我有一些朋友是心理学家、精神科医生、社会工作者，他们越来越多地谈论人们如何带着两到三个标签来预约或咨询。他们会说：“我有BPD，我有双相情感障碍，我有强迫症，我有ADHD。”只有在经过一点调查，或者实际上是因为有些困惑——这个人似乎并不符合标准——他们会询问客户，而客户会说：“哦，我是自己在网上诊断的。”
sometimes they're right that's the thing sometimes these self-diagnosis like you know yourself better than probably anybody so sometimes they're correct but sometimes they're just not and those are the cases that they get really worried about because they're like once you have that label once you really do feel aligned with it it can become a very easy to start seeing everything through that lens. The risk is confirmation bias. We notice the evidence that supports the diagnosis and we overlook the evidence that complicates it. We start collecting examples that fit, forgotten appointments, awkward interactions, bad days and not examples of maybe a more accurate explanation.
有时他们是对的，这就是问题所在。有时这些自我诊断——你知道，你比任何人都更了解自己——所以有时他们是正确的，但有时他们就是不对。而这些正是让他们非常担心的案例，因为他们会说，一旦你有了那个标签，一旦你真的觉得与它一致，就很容易开始通过那个视角看待一切。风险在于确认偏误。我们注意到支持诊断的证据，而忽略了使情况复杂化的证据。我们开始收集符合条件的例子：忘记预约、尴尬的互动、糟糕的日子，而不是那些可能更准确的解释的例子。
This is similar to the risk of over-identification, right? your diagnosis, especially in this case where it's a self-diagnosis made on simplified information, right, without clinical help. It can feel like in that isolated way, it becomes your whole identity rather than just one part of the person that you are in one part of your experience. The problem with that is that it turns as well language and terminology into something that can explain everything and is therefore overly loose and overly casual or even at times aesthetic. And that can really flatten important differences in severity and important differences in experience.
这类似于过度认同的风险，对吧？你的诊断，特别是在这种基于简化信息、没有临床帮助的自我诊断的情况下。在那种孤立的状态下，它可能会感觉像是你的全部身份，而不是你作为一个人的一个部分，也不是你经历的一个部分。这样做的问题在于，它也将语言和术语变成了可以解释一切的东西，因此过于松散、过于随意，甚至有时具有审美意味。这真的会抹平严重程度和经历上的重要差异。
If every mildly relatable struggle is described in the same language as profound, life altering, incredibly difficult, then the people who do and who need the most help become a lot harder to see. If, you know, I'm a bit distracted and I hate admin gets put into the same category as profound difficulties with executive function, that can really make an individual's own experiences feel less seen and less visible. Something important gets lost. Like, we cannot deny that there are variations and their definitions and there are criteria and levels for this very reason. You know, if ordinary sadness is described in the same breath as incapacitating depression, or if discomfort is described in the same breath as trauma, there is meaning that is lost there that is important for literally everybody. That is when you start to see examples of people feeling invalidated, people feeling like they are missing out on understanding, they are missing out on help. because the language that they would typically use to describe their experience has now,
如果每一个轻微的、能引起共鸣的挣扎都被描述为与深刻的、改变生活的、极其困难的经历相同的语言，那么那些真正需要最多帮助的人就变得更难被看见了。如果，你知道，“我有点分心”和“我讨厌行政工作”被归入与“执行功能方面的深刻困难”相同的类别，那真的会让个人自己的经历感觉不那么被看见、不那么显眼。一些重要的东西丢失了。就像，我们不能否认正是因为这个原因才存在差异、定义、标准和级别。你知道，如果普通的悲伤与丧失能力的抑郁症在同一语境下被描述，或者如果不适与创伤在同一语境下被描述，那么这里丢失的意义对每个人来说都是重要的。那就是你开始看到人们感到被否定、感到错失了理解、错失了帮助的例子的时候，因为他们通常用来描述自己经历的语言现在，
and is now used in very general ways that maybe aren't accurate. Maybe aren't accurate, I will say. Sometimes people, again, this is all up for debate and obviously everybody's situation is different. This is just a general trend of what we're seeing with the oversimplification. Listen, I think what I should say is like the role of social media is not simply good or bad. it has the potential to reduce shame, but it also has the potential to spread confusion. Both things are true, and both things are things we should pay attention to. It really does help previously miss people find themselves, especially people for whom these
现在被以非常笼统的方式使用，可能并不准确。也许并不准确，我会说。有时人们，再说一次，这一切都有待商榷，显然每个人的情况都不同。这只是我们看到的过度简化现象的一个总体趋势。听着，我想说的是，社交媒体的作用不仅仅是好或坏。它有减少羞耻感的潜力，但也有传播困惑的潜力。这两者都是事实，而且都是我们应该关注的事情。它确实帮助了以前被遗漏的人找到了自己，特别是那些在他们的环境或家庭中没有进行过这些
conversations are not something that has had in their environment or in their families. But it can mean that that has done in an unsupported way. We have to recognize the paradoxical effect and the flow-on impact that this has on accessibility of services, on pigeonholing, and on the dilution of other people's experiences. The other thing that general, highly stereotyped content made for broad audiences and mass engagement doesn't do is it doesn't understand your context the way that a professional can. Everybody is coming into this space onto social media with so many different things going on. and some of those things would actually explain their behavior and what they're going through
对话的人。但这可能意味着这是以一种不受支持的方式完成的。我们必须认识到这种矛盾的影响，以及这对服务可及性、标签化以及他人经历被稀释所产生的连锁影响。通用、高度刻板且为广泛受众和大规模互动而制作的内容，另一件做不到的事情是，它不像专业人士那样理解你的背景。每个人进入这个空间、进入社交媒体时，都有许多不同的事情在发生，其中一些事情实际上比诊断更能解释他们的行为和他们正在经历的事情。
better than a diagnosis. But if the only video or content they see is like, the only way you can be experiencing this is if you have this, that can become really confusing. I read this piece the other day that talks about how a desire to label everything, every single human behavior is meaning that some parts of the human experience that probably need working on are not being change because it's all coming down to a problem with the individual. So basically, like, everybody is depressed and nobody is investigating the fact that the systems around us are becoming more depressing, right? Everybody is anxious. Everybody could have the label of having an anxiety disorder, but nobody is then focusing on why that is because the world is becoming
但如果他们看到的唯一视频或内容是“你经历这种情况的唯一方式就是你患有这个”，那可能会变得非常令人困惑。前几天我读到一篇文章，谈到对一切事物、每一种人类行为都贴上标签的渴望，意味着人类体验中一些可能需要改进的部分并没有得到改变，因为这一切都归结为个人的问题。所以基本上，每个人都抑郁了，但没有人调查这样一个事实：我们周围的系统正变得越来越令人沮丧，对吧？每个人都很焦虑。每个人都可能被贴上焦虑症的标签，但没有人关注为什么会这样，因为世界正变得
more uncertain, because of financial presses, because of pressures, because of unstable housing, emotional unpredictability. You know, everybody has ADHD and every, everybody like could have the label, but then we're not investigating the fact that, wait a second, maybe the real question is, why does modern life ask people to stare at screens for 12 hours a day? Why does modern life ask people to switch tasks constantly? Why does it ask us to process endless notifications and manage impossible admin and maintain sustained focus under artificial conditions? I could go on. Of course, that is going to have an impact on human attention. I think that everybody would be slightly mentally fragmented under those conditions, but people with ADHD, so much more so.
更加不确定，因为经济压力，因为压力，因为不稳定的住房，情绪不可预测。你知道，每个人都有ADHD，每个人都可能被贴上标签，但我们没有调查这样一个事实：等一下，也许真正的问题是，为什么现代生活要求人们每天盯着屏幕12个小时？为什么现代生活要求人们不断切换任务？为什么它要求我们处理无休止的通知、管理不可能完成的行政工作，并在人工条件下保持持续的专注？我可以继续说下去。当然，这对人类的注意力会有影响。我认为在这些条件下，每个人都会稍微有点精神碎片化，但ADHD患者受到的影响要大得多。
And what's interesting is that they are asking to be given a label, take medication, change all these things. And nobody's thinking, like, wait, why do our systems not support these people? Why does it all come back to, here is a diagnosis, here is the thing that is wrong with you, and not the things that are wrong with how our society has been set up to support you. I listened to this amazing podcast the other day that essentially talked about how modern society is pushing more people into a space where their behavior and their mood is of concern because of how little our current systems actually match what we need as humans or how our brains are designed.
有趣的是，他们要求被贴上标签、服用药物、改变所有这些事情。没有人会想，等一下，为什么我们的系统不支持这些人？为什么这一切都归结为：这是一个诊断，这是你身上出的问题，而不是我们社会为支持你而建立的方式出了问题。前几天我听了一个很棒的播客，它基本上谈到了现代社会是如何将更多人推向一个空间，使他们的行为和情绪令人担忧，因为我们当前的系统与我们作为人类的需求或我们大脑的设计方式相差甚远。
And so, again, no wonder more people see themselves in the symptoms of ADHD or in the symptoms of mood disorders or anxiety or depression when our physical, social, financial, emotional environment is so disrupted. I think the real issue I have with this discussion of like, why does everybody have a diagnosis these days is like, because why wouldn't you relate to these symptoms and why wouldn't you relate to these depictions of these of these conditions and sometimes these disorders when yes, a social media is depicting them as so simplified, but also when life is so awful at times to people that it is actually pushing people into a state that does mimic symptoms of very real conditions and disorders. Obviously, like, this isn't all about environment at all,
所以，再说一次，难怪当我们的身体、社会、经济、情感环境如此混乱时，更多的人在ADHD的症状或情绪障碍、焦虑或抑郁的症状中看到了自己。我认为我对这种“为什么现在每个人都有诊断”的讨论真正的问题在于，为什么你不会对这些症状产生共鸣？为什么你不会对这些病症和有时这些障碍的描述产生共鸣？当社交媒体确实将它们描绘得如此简化，而且当生活有时对人们来说如此糟糕，以至于它实际上将人们推向了一种模仿真实病症和障碍症状的状态时。显然，这根本不是完全关于环境的，
but I think it really does go to show that, like, the individual blame that we place on people or that this discussion would like to place on people is not fair. Like, it is not fair to be, like, to assume that everybody's trying to get attention or putting it on or whatever, like, the idea is that there's some huge biological epidemic, when we can very clearly see all these factors that are really increasing our conversation around mental health and increasing diagnosis rates at times as well. I think at the end of the day, what we're really circling is like, who deserves a diagnosis, deserves being in quotation marks, and who doesn't? And what does a label actually mean? Obviously, it means something. That's why people are so protective over it. That's why
但我认为这确实表明，我们强加给人们的个人指责，或者这种讨论想要强加给人们的指责是不公平的。就像，假设每个人都在寻求关注或装模作样是不公平的，或者认为存在某种巨大的生物学流行病，而我们可以非常清楚地看到所有这些因素确实在增加我们关于心理健康的对话，有时也增加了诊断率。我认为归根结底，我们真正探讨的是：谁值得被诊断（“值得”加引号），谁不值得？标签到底意味着什么？显然，它意味着什么。这就是为什么人们对它如此保护。这就是为什么
it's so closely guarded by clinical guidelines. What does a label mean to people? Why is it important? Why is it discussed? Why is it controversial? We're going to talk more about that after this short break. Pride is like love. You feel it in your heart. IR. Radio. Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts, including IHart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must have party bangers. Plus personalized and curated playlists, like back in the day pride. Come together, celebrate love. Take pride with you anytime, anywhere. Just ask your smart speaker to play IHart Pride Canada. Stream us on your phone or listen now at iHeartRadio.ca.
它受到临床指南的严格保护。标签对人们意味着什么？为什么它很重要？为什么它会被讨论？为什么它有争议？在短暂休息后，我们将讨论更多相关内容。自豪感就像爱。你能在心中感受到它。iHeartRadio。加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用程序，包括iHeartPride Canada，你最喜欢的金曲和必备的派对热歌。加上个性化和精选的播放列表，比如“Back in the Day Pride”。聚在一起，庆祝爱。随时随地带着自豪感。只需让你的智能音箱播放iHeartPride Canada。在手机上收听，或立即访问iHeartRadio.ca。
In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir.
在那一刻，感觉就像持续了永远。我以为我活不下去了。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一个谋杀案吗？是的，长官。
Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape the murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. People, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse,
恐怕这是你职业生涯中最大的案件？是的，长官。强奸并谋杀了一个孩子。这是最糟糕的情况。我想也是。人们，醒醒吧。我是那个亲眼目睹了Krivac和DePippo谋杀案的人。Anthony DePippo没有表现出任何悔意，
appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to The Devil's Quarry on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear The Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges,
在被判处最高刑罚后显得若无其事。我说我没有罪。我会把它带进坟墓。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Devil's Quarry》。要收听无广告且包含独家内容的《The Devil's Quarry》，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是Hoda Kotby，播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》的主持人。我们将一起与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话，比如女演员Olivia Munn分享她是如何克服严峻的健康挑战的，
I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And there's a part of the surprise to me because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human.
我经历过乳腺癌，然后帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更困难。有很多人了解产后抑郁症。我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》。这对我来说有点意外，因为他们的新星是Javier "Chicharito" Hernandez。每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。
Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with. problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist?
每一天，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存，从我出生起就是这样。我仍然有很多问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何处理被取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？
What is love? Real Madrid or Barza? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are sure. This life has an order perfect and everything is just.
什么是爱？皇马还是巴萨？从日常平凡到深刻非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深入交谈，脆弱的一面会显露出来。阴谋论会被摆上桌面，目标和经验会被分享。这个生活有一个完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。
Wait me, I'm going to be able to go to go back. We are here to connect. The Chicharito. Oh, Javier El Chicharro-R-Nandes, and together with I-Had Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It's a carac. Wow.
等等我，我能回去。我们在这里是为了连接。Chicharito。哦，Javier El Chicharito Hernandez，与iHeartRadio一起，我们将让平凡变得非凡。保持关注。这是Carac。哇。
Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how low? legendary you are. I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got like so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped like 30 albums.
在iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learning to be Human》。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Champs》播客上，我们正在与文化界最热门的名字交谈，比如Swae Lee。你意识到你有多传奇吗？我很感激。我看到了，但我心想，伙计，我还有很多事情要做。比如Prince，他发行了大约30张专辑。
We dropped like five right now. Like, that's the rate we got to be going. Yeah, that's a good attitude. You also hear stories from industry legends and hip-hop pioneers like Fab Five Freddy. I directed when Nasda's early videos. Which one? One love. Wow.
我们现在才发行了大约五张。这就是我们必须达到的速度。是的，那是个好态度。你还会听到来自行业传奇和嘻哈先驱的故事，比如Fab Five Freddy。我执导了Nas早期的视频之一。哪一个？《One Love》。哇。
I literally filmed in his apartment in Queensbridge. His moms were still up in that apartment. was just beginning to take off. His pops used to live near me in Harlem. His dad introduced him to a whole lot of, you know, conscious stuff, and he made a young prodigy. No matter the era, Drinkchamps brings you the biggest names
我真的在他的Queensbridge公寓里拍摄的。他妈妈当时还在那个公寓里。他才刚刚开始走红。他爸爸以前住在哈莱姆区我附近。他爸爸向他介绍了许多，你知道，有意识的东西，他造就了一个年轻的天才。无论哪个时代，《Drink Champs》都会为你带来最大的名字
and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So what we're really getting to is like, why is a label important? A formal diagnosis and a label is important. because of the doors that it opens.
和最未经过滤的对话。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听来自Black Effect Podcast Network的《Drink Champs》。所以我们真正要讨论的是：为什么标签很重要？正式诊断和标签很重要，因为它们打开了大门。
Firstly, it opens the door of self-understanding. And whether that's self-diagnosis or a formal diagnosis, I think the understanding is the most crucial part. Research continuously shows that although a diagnosis is a complicated feeling for some, for most it is a relief, and it's self-affirming, and it provides much deeper understanding. A label then also provides access to treatment, relevant accommodations, educational support, workplace adjustments,
首先，它打开了自我理解的大门。无论是自我诊断还是正式诊断，我认为理解是最关键的部分。研究不断表明，尽管诊断对某些人来说是一种复杂的感受，但对大多数人来说，这是一种解脱，是自我肯定的，并提供了更深刻的理解。标签还提供了获得治疗、相关便利、教育支持、工作场所调整、
legal protections, medication, you know, the list goes on. And the reason it provides that is because we live in a society that runs off of systems. And those systems need a clear, reductionist way of categorizing people so they know who gets let in the door, so they know who gets access to what in society. On a structural and service level, governments and healthcare boards need categories, need evidence around prevalence to be able to commission the services to support those people. A lot of countries, granted, are now in a position where they simply cannot keep up with the demand. And there are a lot of complicated factors where governments aren't prioritizing the funding for mental health
法律保护、药物治疗的机会，你知道，名单还在继续。它之所以提供这些，是因为我们生活在一个依靠系统运行的社会中。这些系统需要一种清晰的、还原论的方式来对人进行分类，这样他们才知道谁可以进门，这样他们才知道谁在社会中能获得什么。在结构和服务层面，政府和医疗委员会需要类别，需要关于患病率的证据，以便能够委托服务来支持这些人。诚然，许多国家现在处于一种根本无法跟上需求的境地。而且有很多复杂的因素，政府没有优先考虑心理健康资金，
and for neurodivergent support services and support systems. The problem I have is that then people turn around and blame others who are getting a diagnosis for that problem. and not the fact that this is not a prioritized thing in our society. We are truly worried about more people claiming a diagnosis. You should actually care more about expanding mental health services, nonetheless. Whether you think people are serious or not, whether you think people are just getting that from Instagram, TikTok or not, because having access to a professional will clear up any confusion in any direction. I know that sounds kind of contradictory to like that whole rant I went on about social
也没有优先考虑神经多样性支持服务和支持系统。我的问题是，人们转而指责那些获得诊断的人，而不是指责这在我们的社会中不是一个优先事项。我们真的担心更多的人要求诊断吗？无论如何，你实际上应该更关心扩大心理健康服务。无论你认为人们是否认真，无论你认为人们是否只是从Instagram、TikTok上获得这些，因为获得专业人士的帮助将消除任何方向的困惑。我知道这听起来和我之前关于社交
media before. But like to do a mini summary of what I'm really saying here is that people are very confused and skeptical of increasing rates of certain conditions and they want to put those rates and that rise down to theories about vaccines or changes in the environment or they want to put that down to people making it up or people suddenly over pathologizing. I get the fear. It's very scary for people to see this and think that something's going wrong. And so they're looking for an explanation. It's just that the explanation is a lot bigger and is a lot more complicated.
媒体的那一大段咆哮有点矛盾。但为了对我在这里真正想说的内容做一个小总结：人们对某些疾病发病率的上升感到非常困惑和怀疑，他们想把这些发病率和上升归因于关于疫苗或环境变化的理论，或者他们想把这归因于人们编造它，或者人们突然过度病理化。我理解这种恐惧。人们看到这一点并认为出了问题是非常可怕的。所以他们正在寻找解释。只是这个解释要大得多，也复杂得多。
The real explanation is that the reason we are seeing diagnosis rates increase is that criteria are broadening, more people are finding the language to describe themselves, more people are being identified by mental health systems and being able to self-identify and then get help, which is a good thing. A small portion of those people are being misidentified. and misidentifying themselves because of concept creep, because of social media.
真正的解释是，我们看到诊断率上升的原因是标准正在放宽，更多的人找到了描述自己的语言，更多的人被心理健康系统识别出来，并能够自我识别，然后获得帮助，这是一件好事。其中一小部分人被错误识别了，
Often those people, like it's very rare those people ever get a formal diagnosis anyways because it's not like they're just handing them out like candy. The problem with that small amount of people who are getting the wrong diagnosis is firstly that they actually don't get to understand themselves in the correct way, but also that, you know, the pressure that people are claiming that puts on services. What I'm really saying is like if we actually had more funding for service, us is it wouldn't be a problem, right? Because people would get the help they needed, whether that was a diagnosis or not. Gatekeeping actually helps no one. Like we would have a more accurate idea of how
并且因为概念蔓延、因为社交媒体而错误地识别了自己。通常这些人，很少有人能获得正式诊断，因为诊断并不是像糖果一样随便发放的。那一小部分获得错误诊断的人的问题在于，首先他们实际上没有以正确的方式理解自己，而且，你知道，人们声称这给服务带来的压力。我真正想说的是，如果我们实际上有更多的服务资金，那根本就不是问题，对吧？因为人们会得到他们需要的帮助，无论是否有诊断。设置门槛实际上对任何人都没有帮助。如果我们专注于扩大心理健康资金，而不是把我们的注意力集中在这个关于谁算数、谁不算数的更大辩论上，我们就会对有多少人正在处理心理健康问题、障碍和疾病有一个更准确的了解，无论那是多还是少，我们都能够帮助更多的人，无论他们是否有诊断，无论发生了什么。这有意义吗？因为我不希望这听起来像是：A，这不是一个问题；或者B，自我诊断是一个问题。我们只是因为所有这些因素而看到需求激增，而我们的政府无法应对，这并不是因为人们，不是因为人们在寻求帮助。
many people are dealing with mental health concerns and disorders and conditions, whether that is more or less, we would be able to help more people, regardless of whether they had a diagnosis or not, regardless of what was going on, if we concentrated on expanding mental health funding, rather than focusing or of our attention on this larger debate about who counts and who doesn't. Does that make sense? Because I don't want this to come across as like, A, this isn't a problem, or B, that self-diagnosis is a problem. We're just seeing such an uptick in demand because of all these factors and our governments being able to cope with that, not because of the people, not because it's people seeking help.
这不是他们的错。这是因为他们根本不认为这是优先事项。我认为这就是大问题所在，这就是这一切的归结之处，也是为什么这么多人被迫去寻找语言，被迫去自己寻找解释，这可能给了他们一个不太准确的画面，或者让他们更难获得他们真正需要的帮助，并使他们独自处理这个问题，而没有人在那里给他们一个清晰的自我理解。不幸的是，随着对诊断需求的巨大增加，以及无法或不愿介入的政府系统，我们还看到私营行业正试图在这个市场缺口中赚钱。这些行业的作用不可低估。制药公司显然是我们许多人想到的例子，因为他们确实希望通过任何必要手段让更多人被诊断，这样这些人就成为他们
It's not their fault. It's because they just don't see it as a priority. And I think that's where the big problem, just where this all comes down to and why so many people are forced to go looking for the language and forced to go looking for the explanations by themselves, that perhaps gives them a less accurate picture or less access to the help they really need and makes them deal with this in solitude and without actually somebody there to give them a clear understanding of themselves. unfortunately as well with this huge increase in demand for diagnosis and government systems that can't or won't step up, what we're also seeing is that private industries are looking to make a buck in this gap in the market. And the role of these industries cannot be overstated. Pharmaceutical companies are obviously the example a lot of us think of because they do want more people diagnosed by any means possible so that these people become consumers of their
药物的消费者，对吧？有一部纪录片，我想叫《焦虑时代》（The Age of Anxiety），它是2012年制作的，它在调查大型制药公司如何利用对心理健康支持日益增长的需求方面做得非常出色，无论什么对个人最有利。就像，他们把这种日益增长的需求视为一种赚钱的东西。在20世纪70年代之前，我不知道你们知不知道，医疗性抑郁症（需要药物）和由环境引起的抑郁症（需要更多谈话疗法或更多生活干预，或两者结合）之间有更大的区别。但随着制药公司开始推销抗抑郁药物——顺便说一句，我正在服用，我是它们的忠实粉丝，这不是什么
medications, right? There is this documentary, I think it's called The Age of Anxiety, and it was made in 2012, and it does an amazing job at investigating how Big Pharma has exploited the increasing demand for mental health support, regardless of what's best for the individual. Like, they've seen this increasing demand as a money-making thing. Prior to the 1970s, I don't know if you guys know this, there was a greater distinction between medical, depression that required medication and depression caused by circumstances which required more talk therapy or more, you know, life intervention or a mixture of both. But as pharmaceutical companies began to market antidepressant drugs, which by the way, I'm on, I'm a big fan of, this is not some
阴谋，但随着他们开始推销这些药物，许多人的治疗重点变得更加同质化，对每个人来说都变得更加医疗化。这显然帮助这些公司赚了很多钱，因为他们能够抹去心理健康方面所需的一些区别。私人评估、私人评估诊所、治疗平台、自助品牌、健康应用程序、补充剂公司、生产力工具、教练行业，都受益于这样一种文化：越来越多的人被鼓励认为自己需要解释、标签、治疗、优化、管理，而更少的人能够获得真正的临床服务，获得受过培训、能够真正帮助他们的人的服务。
conspiracy, but as they began to market these drugs, the focus of treatment for many people became more homogenous and it became more medical for everyone. And that obviously helped these companies make a lot of money because they were able to erase some of the distinctions that are required when it comes to mental health. Private assessments, private assessment clinics, therapy platforms, self-help brands, wellness apps, supplement companies, productivity tools, coaching industries, all benefit from a culture where more and more people are encouraged to see themselves as needing an explanation, a label, treatment, optimization, management, and less people have access to actual clinical services with people who are trained, with people who could seriously help them.
我看到过关于人们被骗走数百甚至数千英镑和美元试图寻求ADHD诊断的文章，结果却不被受监管的医疗专业人员正式认可。所以他们实际上甚至无法获得他们需要的支持和药物。有各种各样的例子，针对焦虑症、ADHD、强迫症患者的课程，甚至不是由持牌专业人士制作的，因为人们就像进入了这个市场缺口，而这些课程——我前几天实际上看了一个——太不准确、太简化，简直愚蠢。这非常令人悲伤，因为就像每个人都想关注现在每个人都有问题、诊断是假的一样，
I've seen articles about people being conned out of hundreds, if not thousands of pounds and dollars trying to seek an ADHD diagnosis only for it to not be formally recognized by a regulated healthcare professional. So they actually couldn't even get access to the support and medication that they need anyways. There's all these examples of courses for people with anxiety, with ADHD, with OCD, that aren't even made by licensed professionals because people are like getting into this gap in the market and these courses, I actually was looking at one the other day. I just so inaccurate and simplified and just dumb. And this is so incredibly sad because it's like everybody wants to focus on how everybody has a problem these days and diagnoses are fake.
但人们真的非常渴望帮助，真的非常渴望被倾听和支持。当我们没有找到一个好的方法来满足这种需求并帮助这些人时，无论他们是否有诊断，都有赚钱机器会利用这种缺乏支持的情况。以这种方式构建它是有利可图的，通过标签向人们出售问题的解决方案也是有利可图的。我只是认为，当涉及金钱时，我们需要非常、非常谨慎。再说一次，这并不意味着每个寻求帮助的人都在被操纵。是在不准确地自我诊断吗？绝对不是。
but people are really desperate for help and are really desperate to be heard and supported. And when we do not find a good way to meet that demand and to help these people, whether they have a diagnosis or not, there are money-making machines that will capitalize on that lack of support. There is money in framing it this way and there is money in being able to sell people a solution to their problems through a label. I just think that when there is money involved, we need to be really, really cautious. Again, that does not mean everyone's seeking help is being manipulated. Is self-diagnosing inaccurately? Absolutely not.
这并不意味着药物是坏的，或者临床医生在恶意行事。不，这只是意味着诊断系统不是在真空中存在的。它们作为与政治、经济、临床理解相关的所有这些更广泛因素的一部分而存在。其中一些因素带有激励机制。我们需要意识到这一点，这样我们就不会盲目行事。一些怀疑态度是健康的，不是针对那些试图寻找解释并试图提升自己的人，而是针对任何可能从告诉越来越多的人“他们的痛苦最好被理解为一种可以通过产品、
This doesn't mean that medication is bad or that clinicians are acting in bad faith. No, it just means that diagnostic systems don't exist in a vacuum. They exist as part of all these wider factors to do with politics, to do with economics to do with clinical understanding. And some of those factors come with incentives. And we need to be aware of that so that we're not acting blindly. Some skepticism is healthy, not towards the individuals who are trying to find an explanation and trying to better themselves, but towards any system that might profit from telling more and more people that their distress is best understood as an internal problem that has a label that can be serviced through a product,
服务或订阅来解决的内部问题”中获利的系统，而这些产品、服务或订阅只有他们能卖给你。所以这把我带到了今天的最后一点。考虑到所有这些，过度诊断还是诊断不足更好？这是一个巨大的问题，但我想要拆解它。诊断不足是我们过去的情况。老实说，我认为其中很大一部分是相当悲剧的。
a service or a subscription that only they can sell you. So this brings me to my final point of the day. With all of this in mind, is it better to overdiagnose or underdiagnose? This is a huge question to end on, but I want to break it down. Underedagnosing is what we had in the past. And honestly, I think there are large parts of it that are quite tragic.
它让人们被忽视、得不到支持，并因他人无法理解的挣扎而受到指责。这意味着人们可能会花上几年时间认为自己懒惰、认为自己困难、戏剧化、软弱、破碎。而实际上，他们只是在处理一些从未被认可的事情，而且他们从未能够拥有理解它的语言。这确实有后果。当然，我不需要说，但这影响了我们的自尊、人际关系、财务、我们拥有的生活质量。我们不想回到那种方式。我们不想回到诊断不足的道路上，让人们更难获得帮助。
It leaves people unseen, unsupported, and blamed for struggles others do not understand. It means people can spend years of their life thinking that they are lazy, thinking that they are difficult, dramatic, weak, broken. When in reality, they're just dealing with something that has simply never been recognized and that they were never able to have the language to understand. And that really has consequences. Of course, I don't need to say that, but it impacts our self-esteem, our relationships, our finances, the quality of life that we have. We do not want to go back that way. we do not want to go back to the underdiagnosis path and make it even harder for people to get help.
然而，过度诊断也有其自身的风险。它可能会在无意中将普通的人类变异病理化。它可能会将注意力从我们所处的环境中转移开，而这些环境可能正在描述为什么更多的人会出现严重的症状。它有时会导致人们走向并不完全符合他们作为一个人全貌的解释或治疗。这真的会模糊轻微困难和深刻影响之间的界限。当这种情况发生时，诊断语言可能会开始失去它的一些意义。所以我认为两者并不一定更好。我认为这里的真正目标是诊断得好，诊断得仔细，
Overdiagnosis though has its own risks too. It can pathologize ordinary human variation without meaning to. It can pull attention away from the context that we're in that may be describing why more people are having severe symptoms. And it can sometimes lead people towards explanations or treatments that don't actually fit the full picture of them as a person. and that can really blur the line between mild difficulty and profound impact. And when that happens, diagnostic language can start to lose some of its meaning. So I don't think it's necessarily better to do either. I think that the real goal here is to diagnose well and diagnose carefully,
结合背景，并为对一个人的不断发展的理解留出空间，而不仅仅是一个标签。就像这个人是谁，而不是仅仅把他们看作有这个或那个；他们是谁，他们正在经历什么，他们需要什么语言，标签与否；但随后，他们还需要什么帮助。记住，标签、诊断只是症状或功能模式的集合，它们并不能完全描述一个人。如果你见过一个患有ADHD的人，一个患有自闭症、强迫症、BPD、焦虑症、抑郁症的人，无论它可能是什么，你只是见过一个正在经历那种情况的人，仅仅一个，因为情况总是会不同的。标签之所以是一种过度简化，是因为它需要过度简化事物，以便我们能够对人进行分类。我们需要
contextually, and with room for an evolving understanding of a person, not just a label. like who is this person rather than seeing them as having this or that who are they what are they going through what language do they need label or otherwise but then what what help do they need as well remember like labels diagnoses are just clusters of symptoms or patterns of functioning they do not describe a person entirely if you have met one person who has ADHD one person who has autism OCD, BPD, anxiety, depression, whatever it may be, you have met one person who is experiencing that, just one, because it's always going to be different. A label is an oversimplification for a reason, because it needs to oversimplify things so we can categorize people. We need to
从语境出发，并留有空间去不断理解一个人，而不仅仅是贴上标签。比如这个人是谁，而不是仅仅把他们看作有这样或那样特征的人；他们是谁，他们正在经历什么，他们需要什么样的语言，无论是否贴标签；但更重要的是，他们还需要什么样的帮助。记住，标签和诊断只是症状或功能模式的集合，它们并不能完全描述一个人。如果你见过一个患有ADHD的人，或者一个患有自闭症、强迫症、边缘性人格障碍、焦虑症、抑郁症或其他任何疾病的人，你只是见过一个正在经历这些的人，仅仅是一个，因为每个人的情况总是不同的。标签之所以是一种过度简化，是因为它需要简化事物以便我们对人进行分类。我们需要
instead be focusing on the person. And I know that might seem like a faraway dream because of the strain that resources and services are currently under, but I think that is, is like really the problem that we are getting to. The system is faulty. The system is underserving everybody. I think what that means is that the problem with Undor versus overdiagnosis being turned into an individual issue to deal with. It's turned onto the individual to try and make sense of themselves
而是应该关注人本身。我知道由于目前资源和服务所承受的压力，这似乎是一个遥不可及的梦想，但我认为这确实是我们正在触及的问题所在。系统是有缺陷的。系统未能为每个人提供应有的服务。我认为这意味着，将诊断不足与过度诊断的问题转化为个人需要处理的问题，是错误的。这变成了让个人去试图理解自己。
using whatever resources they have, social media being one of them. And we are being increasingly forced to take care of ourselves without the help of somebody who is trained to do so. And again, regardless of whether you have a diagnosis or not, the pressure should be on the system. It should be on underfunded healthcare systems. It should be on the fact that, you know, rush assessments take place all the time.
利用他们所拥有的任何资源，社交媒体就是其中之一。我们越来越被迫在没有受过专业训练的人员帮助下照顾自己。再说一次，无论你是否被诊断出患有某种疾病，压力都应该施加在系统上。应该施加在资金不足的医疗保健系统上。应该关注这样一个事实，即匆忙的评估一直在发生。
It takes years to get an assessment for something. Schools support systems are not good at putting in place healthcare plans or identifying children who could need help. Like I can just go on and on it. Like the private companies come in and are like, we can make a buck off of making everybody believe that they are not well without actually caring about anybody who is not well. So I just think that's like something to really be conscious of.
获得某种评估需要数年时间。学校的支持系统在落实医疗保健计划或识别可能需要帮助的儿童方面做得并不好。我可以一直说下去。比如私营公司进来，就像是说，我们可以通过让每个人相信自己不健康来赚钱，而实际上并不关心任何真正不健康的人。所以我认为这确实是需要真正意识到的一点。
I'm going to finish up this episode with a quick summary, of which I've done several, but a proper summary for this topic. Why does everybody have a diagnosis these days? Point one, not everybody has a diagnosis these days. Yes, rates are increasing, but they are just catching up to an underlying prevalence rate that has always been there. For conditions like depression and anxiety, those rates are incredibly high and that is a real concern and that is showing that there is something changing in our society and happening in our society and there have been things
我将用一个简短的总结来结束这一集，虽然我已经做过几次总结，但这是针对这个主题的一个正式总结。为什么现在每个人都有诊断结果？第一点，现在并不是每个人都有诊断结果。是的，发病率在上升，但它们只是赶上了一直存在的潜在患病率。对于抑郁症和焦虑症等疾病，这些比率高得惊人，这是一个真正令人担忧的问题，这表明我们的社会正在发生变化，并且正在发生一些事情，而且已经有一些事情
happening in our society that are deeply, deeply impacting everybody, really. When it comes to other conditions though, rates do seem to be increasing, but a large majority of this rate increase is coming down to people who previously, historically should have been diagnosed, but they were not included by diagnostic criteria. They didn't have the language they weren't seen or their case or the way that they represented didn't match stereotypes. Some people are mislabeling normal human idiosyncrasies with catch-all, inaccurate terms. There's coming from social media and other sources. But, But it is not our job to be concerned with how an individual chooses to see themselves.
在我们的社会中发生，确实对每个人都产生了非常深远的影响。然而，当谈到其他疾病时，发病率似乎确实在上升，但这种增长的绝大部分归因于那些在历史上本应被诊断出来，但却未被诊断标准涵盖的人。他们没有相关的语言，他们没有被看到，或者他们的情况或表现方式与刻板印象不符。有些人用笼统、不准确的术语给正常的人类特质贴上错误的标签。这来自社交媒体和其他来源。但是，关注个人选择如何看待自己并不是我们的工作。
And we should be more focused on ensuring that that person can get in and see a clinician, that person can get help, then we should be it trying to correct whether whatever they are experiencing is true or false in our eyes. We also need to be skeptical of a lot of systems around us right now that are trying to make more people feel like something is wrong with them, especially when they can make money from it, especially when they seek to gain from the oversimplification of mental health language. So make sure that you are looking out for that. Make sure that you are aware of the systems in place that may be manipulating certain parts
我们应该更专注于确保那个人能够去看临床医生，那个人能够得到帮助，而不是试图在我们眼中纠正他们所经历的一切是真是假。我们还需要对周围许多试图让更多人觉得他们有问题系统保持怀疑，特别是当他们能从中获利时，特别是当他们试图从心理健康语言的过度简化中获益时。所以一定要确保你对此保持警惕。确保你意识到那些可能正在操纵某些部分的系统
of distress or impairment happening in your life. But again, it is a really complicated thing. and until we have more money and until we have more research and until we have the care towards this and just towards humanity that we actually need. Like we're going to continue to see this debate like be very intense and continue to see people perhaps suffering and struggling in ways that they don't really need to. I'm going to finish it there. We did it.
你生活中出现的痛苦或障碍。但同样，这是一件非常复杂的事情。在我们有更多的资金、更多的研究以及我们真正需要的对这一领域和对人类的关怀之前，我们将继续看到这种争论非常激烈，并继续看到人们可能以他们并不真正需要的方式遭受痛苦和挣扎。我就讲到这里。我们做到了。
This is the biggest episode of the year so far. I think it's the longest episode of this year. If you've made it to the end, thank you. I hope it stirred up some thinking for you. hope that it taught you something new or just gave you a better bird's eye view of the situation. I know some of you won't agree with everything that I said. Totally welcome feedback. I would love to hear it.
这是今年到目前为止最重要的一集。我认为这是今年最长的一集。如果你坚持到了最后，谢谢你。我希望它能激发你的一些思考。希望它教会了你一些新东西，或者只是让你对这种情况有了更好的鸟瞰视角。我知道你们中的一些人不会同意我所说的一切。非常欢迎反馈。我很乐意听到。
If this is also something that you and your friends have been discussing, like me and my friends, send it to them is still an evolving conversation. And I feel like, it's like, it's one of those things. Like we just don't have answers to it. Like the only answer is like more money and more help, but that's kind of unrealistic. Besides that, though, if you and your friends again have been talking about it, send this episode to them, maybe you guys can keep chatting about it. Me and my friends have actually been doing this thing where we've been doing like a podcast book club. So basically it's like a book club,
如果这也是你和你的朋友一直在讨论的话题，就像我和我的朋友一样，发给他们吧，这仍然是一个不断演变的话题。我觉得这就像是那种事情。我们只是没有答案。唯一的答案似乎是更多的资金和更多的帮助，但这有点不切实际。除此之外，如果你和你的朋友再次讨论过这个问题，把这一集发给他们，也许你们可以继续聊下去。我和我的朋友们实际上一直在做这件事，我们一直在搞一个播客读书俱乐部。所以基本上它就像一个读书俱乐部，
but for podcasts where we listen to like five podcast episodes a month and then get together and discuss them, this can be one of your podcast episodes. I want to hear your thoughts. I want to thank our wonderful researcher Libby for her wonderful research. contributions to this episode. She is truly magnificent and she's been doing some work on this very topic, which is just like so exciting. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram, on substack. If you want to read the full version of this, you can also DM me, you can email me, you can leave a comment down below, you can watch full episodes on Netflix. There's so much that you can do with this episode. But yeah, I hope you enjoyed it and I just genuinely hope that it
但针对的是播客，我们一个月听五集播客，然后聚在一起讨论它们，这可以成为你们的播客剧集之一。我想听听你们的想法。我要感谢我们出色的研究员Libby为这一集所做的精彩研究贡献。她真的很棒，她一直在研究这个话题，这真是太令人兴奋了。确保你在Instagram和Substack上关注我们。如果你想阅读完整版本，你也可以私信我，你可以给我发电子邮件，你可以在下面留下评论，你可以在Netflix上观看完整剧集。关于这一集你可以做很多事情。但是的，我希望你喜欢它，我真诚地希望它
stirred up feelings and thoughts for you and, yeah, it's going to start some more conversations. With that in mind, as always be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo.
激发了你的感受和想法，并且，是的，它将引发更多的对话。考虑到这一点，一如既往，请保持安全，保持友善，善待自己。我们很快就会再聊。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。邪恶，醒醒。我是那个看到Crevette和DePippo谋杀案发生的人。
Anthony DePippo showed no sense. signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential, and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101.
Anthony DePippo没有表现出任何悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我会把它带到坟墓里。在IHeart Radio应用程序上收听Bone Valley Feed中的魔鬼采石场。Apple Podcasts，或者任何你获取播客的地方。快乐是必不可少的，但它也是难以捉摸的。但现在，有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开启你通往更快乐生活的旅程。Joy 101。
It's a new podcast hosted by me. HOTA Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes,
这是一个由我主持的新播客。Hoda Kotby。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心和感人的直播聊天。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索Joy 101并立即收听。由CVS呈现的Hoda Kotby主持的Joy 101。每个人都视我为足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。每一天我仍在学习如何处理问题、错误、
relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is just a instantaneous, real and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier El Chichariot Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. For years, the unhoused have been presented as a monolith in mainstream media. Whedian House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created the show why I was unhoused on the streets of Los Angeles. We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast.
关系、情绪，从我出生起就是这样。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即时的、真实的、真诚的，只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是Javier El Chichariot Hernandez，在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听Learning to Be Human。多年来，无家可归者在主流媒体中一直被呈现为一个单一的群体。Whedian House是一个正在改变这种叙事的播客。我是Theo Henderson，我在洛杉矶街头无家可归时创建了这个节目。我们已经成长为一个两次获得Webby奖的播客。
The only podcast that shares unhoused stories and news from the unhoused perspective. Listen to Wey and House on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akila Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority of black city in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit season two on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
唯一一个从无家可归者视角分享无家可归者故事和新闻的播客。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听Wey and House。这里有一件事不应该像现在这样复杂，那就是移除种族主义雕像。这里还有一件事应该比现在容易得多，那就是在原处放置一个新的雕像。我是Akila Hughes，Rebel Spirit第二季就是关于这两件事的。当我在看这些雕像被拆除时，我在想，我在一个黑人占多数的城市长大，那里纪念奴隶主的地方比纪念被奴役者的地方多，这意味着什么。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听Rebel Spirit第二季。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是人类创作。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。